do you think
that there are too many
superhero shows and movies and because I
remember when I did Smallville yes there
were none yeah I do think there's too
many so what do you do about that um but
I don't think it's it's not it's it's
much less a problem of too many and yes
we are going to
we're not going to overextend ourselves
at DC we're going to be very careful
with the product that we put out and
making sure everything is as good as it
can possibly be
um
but
I think that what's happened is people
have gotten really lazy with their
superhero stories and they have gotten
the place where oh it's a it's a
superhero let's make a movie about it
you know and they make oh let's make a
sequel because the first one did pretty
well
and they aren't thinking about why is
this story special what makes this story
stand apart from other stories
what is the story at the heart of it all
why is this character important what
makes this story different that it it
fills a need for people in theaters to
go see you know or on television and
that's a hard thing isn't it and I think
that is just that that's kind of gotten
you know people have gotten a little
lazy and there's a lot of you know Biff
pow bam stuff happening in in movies and
like I'm watching third acts of
superhero films where I really just
don't and I don't feel like there's a
Rhyme or Reason to what's happening I
don't care I don't care about the
characters right you know and it's like
and and they've gotten too generic like
there's this sort of
um
you know middle of the road
uh you know type of
you know genre tone that so many
superhero movies have as opposed to
having you know you know very different
genres I mean I like very serious
superhero movies I like very comedic
superhero movies I like ones that are
really just you know you know a murder
mystery but it's you know with
superheroes you know I like to see these
different types of stories as opposed to
seeing the same story told over and over
again I don't know how many times I you
know I don't want to go off anything no
you're not right well it's honest and I
think people really need to hear that
because it's it's sincere in a sense
that you're also a fan and you want to
make movies that have impact that have
them that people want to see and not
recycle things you want to sort of
condense it to a let's make something
that we really not that people don't
work hard on everything they do
everything everybody works hard but the
stories have to be more compelling yeah
and I I think that also like and then
people say superhero fatigue but I think
that that you know you see now that it's
not a real thing people have are
fatigued with repetition and I I don't
think it's really just superhero movies
I think you're seeing it happening now
it's spectacle films in general you know
I think it's more than that I think
when's the last great comedy can you
remember remember the last great comedy
yeah but there are so few of them made
that you don't have you know but but but
there's a lot of spectacle films made
and they just have gotten really generic
and they've gotten boring and they
aren't about characters and there's no
emotion to them and there's there should
be emotion and Things No Matter What
like that should always be there some
type of emotion I'm not saying it can't
be really light I'm not saying it can't
be really heavy I'm saying there should
be some sort of you're right and that
goes with horror and comedy everything
that's right it's just all this you
gotta care like in a horror movie if you
like that main character then you're
much more scared when they're about if
you care about them exactly if you take
the time to make mistakes matter and it
doesn't even matter big star ours think
about it if you put out a movie let's
say James Gunn put out a movie with DC
for DC or you made another Marvel's a
suicide what's this guy was DC but if
you put it out there and it was a bunch
of no names
if the trailer's great people are going
to see it they don't care if so-and-so's
in my opinion especially horror movies
maybe not as much in the big Marvel DC
Universe maybe you need some stars but
like for them no I'm telling you you
know I know it's much more important to
me that the actor fits the role